[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers concitoyens l'élection
présidentielle c'est un moment clé
c'est un moment formidable en réalité
parce que c'est celui où un peuple tout
entier décide du chemin qu'il va suivre
[Musique]
ce peuple c'est vous et je suis venu
vous dire une chose très simple nous les
citoyens français nous le peuple
français
nous avons les moyens de nous en sortir
nous pouvons nous en sortir
il faut concentrer nos efforts tous les
efforts de la nation tous les efforts du
pays sur des priorités soigneusement
choisis je vous propose d'abord de
recréer des emplois des emplois pour les
jeunes qui manquent de temps pour les
adultes qui ont charge de famille
retrouvé de l'emploi c'est choisir un
mot d'ordre c'est produire chez nous
produire en france et consommer français
pour soutenir la production du pays
[Musique]
deuxième priorité nous devons
désendetter la france
personne n'en parle dans cette campagne
électorale est cependant le
surendettement d'un pays est aussi grave
que le surendettement d'une famille
alors bien sûr il y aura des économies à
faire
mais il ya tant de gaspillage autant de
mauvaise organisation que ces économies
nous pourrons les trouver sans porter
atteinte aux services qu'on doit rendre
aux français et à leurs familles
troisième choix nous devons retrouver
l'éducation nationale qui faisait la
fierté de notre pays
alors bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
décisions il ya beaucoup de réformes à
faire mais j'en propose une que tout le
monde comprendra tous les enfants quel
que soit leur milieu d'origine que tous
ces enfants maîtrisent la lecture
l'écriture le calcul et même l'amour de
la langue française
alors nous leur offrirons la clé de
toutes les réussites ultérieure
[Musique]
ce
puis quatrième impératif sans confiance
ya pas de redressement
la confiance ça passe par
l'établissement de règles nouvelles et
simple qui sont celles de tous les
grands pays du monde et que nous avons
perdus de vue il ya longtemps
pour ça il faut des décisions très
simple il faut que l'on mette un terme
au cumul des mandats il faut que les
parlementaires soient désormais présent
l'assemblée nationale et vote en
personne et que les votes soient
publiques
il faut qu'on reconnaisse le vote blanc
[Musique]
ses quatre priorités produire et
consommer en france désendetter le pays
retrouvait la meilleure éducation du
monde et moraliser la vie publique pour
que nous en soyons fiers c'est le chemin
du redressement que notre pays attend et
c'est le seul moyen de lui rendre ce mot
qui lui manque depuis si longtemps
le mot espoir
[Musique]